you
well here we go it's three seconds until
kickoff this is an hourly bullet arena
got some heavy hitters up top for sure
Alex round one he's stunned by d4
okey-dokey let's grab some space and
develop stop b5
and weasel the night around
nothing fancy
Bishop f4 I think I want to trade light
square bishop
now let's clamp down here first yeah
I can't do this just yet clean up and
then Bishop here probably win that Phan
rook d4
might be a little bit uncomfortable with
their back rank
I'll see 93
that rook is a little bit awkward
okay I'm definitely floundering some
here
yeah
and that won't be any good yeah I'm
dropping stuff now okay yeah I'm
dropping a lot of stuff there down on
time though maybe I could be a magician
with the night
I guess I have to try for that ah it's
not cool this is going to be tough
yikes
I'm going to be able to blitz out a lot
of moves
a halt I want to quit the tournament ah
when in a game like that is just so so
bad ah it's such a bad that was such a
bad game just like ah ugliness man it's
just ugliness you know I've ever played
an ugly game have you ever just have you
ever seen someone playing ugly game you
just saw it
ah man ugly ugly ugly miss I had Swiss
cheese for pawns ah holes everywhere
that's a free night okay
shake that one off all right I could
grab some more stuff but uh and I didn't
want to take these seven it's some more
material they're allowing up they're
giving me a lot of free stuff here
I need the free stuff throw in a check
of Queen here I got a boatload of
material here a boatload let's see if we
could pull off a mate soon sneaking in
looking for mate on h7 clean s to go
there huh here comes the rook mate next
unavoidable that was a little better
although my opponent was a bit on the
generous side in that one ah if we get
paired up again myself and Alex I
definitely have to put in a better
showing there ah man rata ffice round
three who in the chat was saying try
some fishing poles
we're gonna go for it here there we go
sneak it in there ah h2 strikes an
in-betweener a sneak artist tactic you
see I didn't recapture on c6 there you
could do that you can get away with that
one right there they were in a little
bit of a pre move each two strikes and
with that I have 8 points let's try it
again
I like um I've shared this on the last
stream I like trying the fishing pole
against players where it's still zero
zero haven't played before maybe they
don't know that I'm a fisherman at the
chess board
all right good versus bad bishop give
him a boot yeah maybe I give up this guy
now let's give a check first hmm
knight on f5 is pretty good
I could have won material
kind of capture the night and then
captured here
oh well this should be pretty strong
though night on d3 ready to bring the
pain can I win the Queen yes I could
what at the direct fork there I don't
have to get fancy with the discoveries
and there we go now we're going to be an
infiltrator an infiltrator it takes
why I hesitated so much there I don't
need to castle here
h4 rook c8 time edge piece material edge
piece material edge more material and
are they gonna drop on time soon they're
in a pin here we go
no stalemates mayn't next note they're
down on time okay there are 76 players
20 minutes still
average legend in the chat is saying
happy little mates ha they're more Bob
Rostock going on in the chat probably
okay we're gonna need a little more
support for that all right now we could
get it in
let's give him a boot see where he goes
can't take I got a pin there goes the
Queen it's just probably unnecessary
let's take to open up just a hair more
and then oh now we're winning even more
material
alright let's drop all the way back
I'd like to rattle this position now my
bishop is super super Bishop Discoverer
check another check
and then snag that rook main threat new
queen on the scene
yeah that should be me very soon they
resigned back to tournament
okay
let's do it again I got 16 with fire a
couple pretty quick ones in there
in early d5 okay so I have a majority in
the center let's secure my night they're
gonna start to hammer away at d4 or at
least I thought they would they why do
you call them they is it a male or
female it is my opponent male or female
I just don't know so I'm gonna go with
DES all right this is just even town
maybe I feel like I want to take him out
and where exactly to go with my king I
guess we're gonna castle and drop upon
but a valuable can those BB pawns be
let's rattle this Bishop best or the
they're better minor piece you go there
yes noted although I'm okay with a trade
more active rook oh that could have been
a move yeah that would have been painful
I realized that one a bit too late I got
a flight square double attack against
the bishop and pawn oh they missed that
I was on the bishop alright let's just
make sure I get behind the pond and drop
my off pawn in the process okay any
tricky Forks there's one we gotta hurry
up here on the clock on the clock we
have to hurry I just want a stable
square can I find a stable square for my
knight where's the stability okay we got
some stability check another check and
the other checks okay I need to
a better job of converting this not even
close to converting this I already get
made
this is terrible I'm playing this is
terrible
no stalemates I could actually oh I want
on time but I could just run it run all
the way to g8 could run all the way
there and be checkmate all the King
could do from that position is go back
and forth on h2 and h1
that was a very very poor technique I've
maybe played one decent game here out of
the six we got the co-pilot
up all right we're gonna play with c4
this time
and yeah let's go for this setup more
positional can probably play these
positions faster
more more control I'll take him
and now we have a a passed on connected
past pond
I like to see a light square bishop
exchange so that's what I'm gunning for
got it
maybe I pushed soon or not I want to
reposition my queen she's a bit too
offensive too strong
h5 Queen f5 maybe Queen of five right
away what's that about got that one
covered
hit that lady's off she had to go to the
corner to avoid the exchange and now we
pushed through get these phones rolling
too they continue to push got some more
material and they threw in the towel
24:14 change left the Romeo 24k is
saying your queen is offensive protrader
first time player I might have to go
fishing now it doesn't quite work
against d4 this is a fun line the knight
c6 coupled with e5 I guess we'll take
post up mmm asking for some some trouble
maybe I thought with this I want to go
Queen side yeah I'll go that way as well
I want to solidify the center
it's a poison pond I'm pretty sure yeah
took him he took the poison he's trapped
I want I want my be pond around as the
shelter
let's target that guy if the bishop is
given up I'm going to get on
get on this diagonal as soon as possible
and this is made on the spot bishops
controlling that b1 squarely its knifing
in there
okay we got 12 and change
right about the halfway points strike
Eric on
I've played this variation maybe more
than any other variation ooh I could
still go there
pick that bishop up I don't think that
this is the greatest line I think CDs
are better replies to the bishop blocks
so that there's Queen b3 oh I guess
we're gonna try to attack the Queen goes
too far I have Queen takes Knight
they're out of the pin straight away
let's throw some more pieces at the king
queen g4 threatens me let's just back up
for the moment coming at me pretty hard
alright let's start throwing some
punches here
okay defended noted let's just patrol
this diagonal my queen is a very good
defending piece as well of b2 this is
nice
Queen exchange okay I feel more
comfortable doing this now and I could
probably look two targets hmm that's a
pretty good move
oh I wasted a lot of time just then whoa
you greedy player you can't believe they
would do that
what did I do to deserve that I was so
greedy I don't want that Rick to get
active
they takes pawn rook takes pawn I'm in a
good position now they stuff to sort out
their back rank stop him from getting
active cut the ruck off stop this knife
from getting here take some more squares
away from the knight let's keep the
Knights on sort of boxed out um let's
just drop back good take that where's
that nightgown where is he going and
save that guy
oh that's tricky night but I just got uh
trying to push my pawn man
kill the night you're gonna have a
better time if you kill the night
you
hello my goodness it's just a rat race
why are you watching why are you
watching a rat race oh man can I can I
win a game by checkmates can I win by
checkmates mrs. Robinson is up okay ah I
figured they were gonna do that they
were they were in prima mode
I got an h-file in a fork now I'm
dropping upon really
that's all that's really going on I'll
go the same side giving up another pond
let's keep it closed the rooks are
scaring me
let's kill that night I want to get my
king over here
copycat I was just being a copycat
flight square too early for that
maybe Queen trade take what the pawn I
want to have a grip over these squares
drop my knight in to see for one day get
him back involved this is an open file
get there what are you waiting for
they're gonna kick my bishop back hang
on to that pawnees important I have a
very good square now I wanna get rid
this Knight drop upon the process they
don't want him 33 seconds they
why you why are you saying they now this
is mrs. Robinson you know the gender
this time around you're still doing it I
should have captured that bishop
okay now we're gonna bring the pain
there's a fork they resigned Forks are
painful okay we got to say I'm on board
Forks are painful Forks are painful I
wonder if there's some stat out there
you know where you know what chest
tactic can you get like what chest
tactic are you hit with that prompts
resignation more often than any other
it'd probably be it would probably be
a fork they're just they're painful no
way around it
whoo queen is lacking some squares she's
cooked
that's a cooked Queen
got em all covered back to tournament
got 40 got fire seven in change all
right there are a hundred and nine in
this one
7:12 nor hotshot let's go with e4 I
might try a quick scholars mate I have
pulled those off before you know I
followed for him but I've also uh dished
out some scholars mates as well
was a very quick investment of the
bishop pair oh why did I do that this
guy's playing really fast I am down a
full rook what do you do when you're
down a full rook
I mean seriously I'm gonna play there
they had that guy huh where is he going
I need a new flight square
gotta open this up think spend some time
to think that's what I need you to do
right now
spend a lot of time trying to find best
moves this night might be trapped soon
uh I guess here stop that night no
trades they're gonna grab the pond no
trace
no trades now the Queen let's keep that
pawn around controlling f6
where's the miracle where is the miracle
are we close to a miracle halfway there
were halfway there
it's almost happening it's almost there
we're on the night
oh hang on he's dangerous
we know this you get coordinated fast
really fast
where's the miracle oh they don't have
any time either they're down on time B 3
B 3 Oh red B 3 that's a wonderful pre
booth beats rev3 Bishop takes Knight of
free B and then a rook
ah man we've been here before myself and
Alex we have definitely been here before
in a slower game
in a 5-minute game in the marathon game
all right I'm going king hunting
they're gonna try to stop that here we
go this pawn is a killer
maybe all right I am once again down
upon but I have a have a decent
structure I don't know maybe I get to
the second rank maybe
this would be helpful they took their
got some activity my b2 putting the
pressure on
grab that pond ah they're lining up some
fancy stuff there I need to secure my
bishop
they just undermined it um
I guess we'll take here interesting rook
and pawn ending grab the a pawn and then
stop there H fun can I pull that off I
need to get one of the pawns
I need to get a passed pawn I need to
get behind on behind
save him and then run I got to push my
past fun run keep running that's a check
I got behind run
I have a time edge
don't fall for mate
it'd be a time burning machine keep the
rocks on
not as easy to pre move down on time a
decent edge
down upon but I had some activity that's
about it they were breaking down my
bishop position very good though by the
way I do not have a lead I'm at our I
need this one right here Matty D is on
board
just take I'm back three I am in second
just realizing this now let's shoot that
Bishop away shoo him away my knight
savage stranded that move
I want my queen right on d4 or even b2
is pretty good pointing at g7 that's a
pretty weakening move Bishop c4 oh you
bugger to give up my dark square bishop
they don't want him take him okay we're
gonna hang on to him then
we got a minute 17 left that guy could
win at any moment let's get this night
out of there man
uh here I guess
yeah even on time
yikes
my dropping material what a bugger
maybe I finally get some coordination my
Bishop's close to being trapped
yeah I guess we'll go here I want to try
to
dent in their structure somehow it's not
easy a little bit of a time edge
that's just throwing the time burner
all right we're just going to go for
some time burners now open it up
hopefully they can't adjust
as quick
two seconds
time Vernors
they're doing time burners as well
who five seconds and did I get that one
in holy cow I did get that one in but it
wasn't enough
oh man I didn't even have time to look
at the the game clock or anything that
was such a messy tournament whoo we were
both uh-oh he started off berserk in the
first three same number of games very
good I took second 55 in first 5230
there's a bit of a drop off for third
and beyond 13 below 30 28 119 and all
all right let's have a look at page two
three four five many pages this is an
arena so you definitely get a bigger
turnout when it's not a created
tournaments and that's gonna do it
twelve pages all right to the 118 of you
good games off
whoo I feel like I already need to take
a breather man
you